to open the first one because we're
going to announce the Kia all NBA team
all right we'll start with the third
team okay
that I think I'll take it the other way
no we're going third team first well
then everybody gonna know who the first
and second guys are man they're gonna
know anyway because they're gonna read
the names third Team all NBA the guards
dear and fox of the Sacramento Kings and
Damian Lillard of the Portland
Trailblazers the forwards LeBron James
and Julius Randle and the center
third team domantas sabonis
wow okay reactions anything uh not until
I had to hit him I know well yeah but
those names you're happy to see anybody
on there that's a bonus I was happy to
see it's a bonus and dare and fox and I
had a great year obviously did not end
well but great year second Team all NBA
the guards
Stephen Curry of Golden State Donovan
Mitchell of the Cleveland Cavaliers
Jalen Brown of Boston Jimmy Butler of
Miami the forwards and the center Nicola
jokic of the Denver Nuggets oh
oh
and what why you oh Owen
um well you know MVP second guys on the
second team there's a center yeah yeah
well I thought we were going
positionless again not yet next year we
go positionless okay next year we go
positionless so it could be embiid and
jokic I understand that because okay
remember when they do that All-Star
thing they just said pick it but this is
all NBA next okay next year position
next year are you ready for first team
yes First Team all NBA
guards Luka doncic of the Dallas
Mavericks Shea gilges Alexander yes I'm
happy for him the forwards Giannis
antetokumpo of Milwaukee Jason Tatum of
Boston and the center your MVP Joelle
embiid okay you've heard them all now
wow Chuck you've heard them all
right okay go ahead I want to say
congratulations to
Tatum
and his partner because they were
bragging about it those guys make all
the NBA the new contracts that they're
going to get so congratulations those
guys well deserved but whoever made the
list first second third team
it's a big accomplishment to a lot of
guys playing in the league so it's just
an honor that's well deserved I have no
problem with whoever's on I'm really
happy for Shea guidras Alexander Gill
just Alexander he played his tail off
this year and you know LeBron had 45-30
point games LeBron even though he's 38
still 13 on NBA but I have no problem
with anybody that's on the list
I thought Darren Fox would be on at
least second team personally
I thought him as a bonus were terrific
all year they finish with the third best
record in the west so I was surprised I
thought I thought Fox should have been
second team personally
well you know I don't think I have a
problem with anybody when you say 15
guys you can throw them in a blender mix
them up and you you probably still come
out correct with the reception of maybe
two or three guys they always would be
in that first team ballot
um shake it was Alexander you know you
go from
nowhere to everywhere today in one day
man in one year he puts in the work
um
I get opportunity at times because in
Los Angeles he works out with my main
man the guard Whisperer out there in L.A
so I get to see him work out firsthand
he puts in work guys so um congrats to
Shay congrats to Luca and
to mvpnb as well I was happy for Shea
because he I I was worried that you know
we don't show Oklahoma City uh at all
number one and I'm glad he made it first
team
uh but like I said obviously all 15 of
these guys are incredible players but I
was a little surprised that uh Darren
Fox wasn't the least second team
there are some other players receiving
votes I'm glad you asked I was about to
go there other guards receiving votes
John Morant Drew holiday Jalen Brunson
Booker was fourth among those guards
others receiving votes among the
forwards Laurie Lowry markinen Kevin
Durant Pascal siacom Kawhi Leonard
Anthony Edwards those are your top five
and you think about Anthony other
centers where Anthony Davis bam out of
bio
yeah I think certain guys man it's it's
gonna be interesting next year let's say
if all of these guys that you named on
that list that didn't make it are
healthy
five centers if you wanted two on that
first yeah that list is going to change
dramatically next year I think so too oh